companies that recycle cardboard boxes
are overwhelmed after record holiday
shopping online the US Postal Service
estimated it would deliver 10% more
holiday packages in 2017 than the year
before
Amazon the leader in online shopping
says it shipped more than five billion
items for Prime members in 2017 and all
of that cardboard is a huge recycling
challenge Jamie yuccas is at a recycling
center in Southern California's San
Fernando Valley to show us what happens
to all of it Jamie good morning good
morning this vale of boxes wastes close
to a ton but amazon says redesigning its
packaging has helped it a void ship 307
million more boxes that's 550,000 semi
trucks full but you can see online
shoppers are doing so much buying
recycling centers are struggling to keep
up one after another a train of trucks
unloads at this Los Angeles area
recycling center Natasha Gagarin emptied
an SUV packed with empty boxes pony
boxes do you think you had in your car
oh well over 200 well over as a mom of
four this holiday season was all about
convenience did you do a lot of your
ordering online this year all on Amazon
in the US alone Amazon used six thousand
trucks and 32 planes to get packages to
its prime members last year and keep
bringing it in yeah
Craig hampel is the recycling
coordinator for the city of Burbank
are you seeing an increase in the amount
of cardboard absolutely it's a tsunami
of cardboard everything goes up 5 10%
during the holidays that's a concern for
hampel because the recycling process is
so complex the boxes are sorted and
bundled here then he says they're loaded
into containers and shipped across the
Pacific to China
there the boxes are soaked in water
stripped of staples and reborn as boxes
there might be a 12,000 mile loop in a
lot of the packaging that we buy and and
send back for recycling
but amazon says they put a new focus on
sustainable packaging moving over a
hundred
million shipments from boxes to padded
mailers in 2017 they released this video
we make those kinds of packaging easy to
open minimal waste and 100% recyclable
as a result I mean today we've
eliminated one hundred and eighty one
thousand tons of waste but centers like
these are still overwhelmed after the
holidays as many shoppers seem to prefer
buying online in December and recycling
their boxes in January so you don't
think maybe I'll go to the mall and not
have to deal with this trip never ever
ever ever and just this trip compared to
the hours at the mall and the people in
the parking you can't find it and Witte
in lines that the cash registers and the
people that are just rude and ugly I
wouldn't trade it for the world
Amazon does have a challenge in terms of
its packaging because it wants it to
come compact but also intact when it
gets to your door
now all this cardboard recycling centers
say likely won't be cleared out until
close to February Jeff alright Jamie
thank you very much